hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live eine un Klimakonferenz in Dubai mit
einem ölboss als Präsident klingt absurd
findet aber aktuell genauso statt es ist
die 28 Kop wie sie abgekürzt genannt
wird zwei Wochen lang beraten rund
80.000 Forscher Expertin und vor allem
Entscheider aus Politik und Wirtschaft
darüber wie man die Erderwärmung
verlangsamen kann
vor hat man das schon lange ganz
offiziell seit der Cop in Paris 2015 wo
sich die gesamte un zu dem Ziel bekannt
hat die Erderwärmung auf 1,5° möglichst
zu begrenzen dieses Ziel ist Leid weit
weg laut einem neuen UN-Bericht steuert
die Welt auf ein Plus von bis zu 2,9° zu
ist die Erderwärmung noch zu stoppen was
bringt so eine Klimakonferenz überhaupt
auf der im letzten Jahr die Zahl der Öl-
und gaslobbyisten die Teilnehmerzahl der
meisten nationalen Delegation
überschritten hat einige AktivistInnen
boyottieren die Veranstaltung deshalb
Deutschlands bekannteste
klimaschutzaktivistin Luisa Neubauer von
Fridays for future deutschland ist nach
Dubai gereist und wir können gleich mit
ihr sprechen sie schrieb bei Ex bei
aller Kritik aktuell ist die Cop der
einzige Ort der theoretisch das
Potenzial hat das Pariser Abkommen
umzusetzen wir wollen heute über die
Kritik an der Cop aber auch über die
Kritik an der Fridays for future
Bewegung der letzten Wochen und
natürlich über Klimaschutz sprechen
Luisa Neubauer ist uns jetzt live aus
Dubai zugeschaltet ihr könnt Fragen an
Sie stellen direkt im Stream oder per
Mail hallo schön dass Sie bei uns
sind hallo Sie haben bei Ex sich im
Vorfeld geäußert ich hatte sie eben
schon kurz zitiert sie haben außerdem
noch was geschrieben sie haben
geschrieben die diesjährige Kop sei kein
ehrlicher kein transparenter Ort kein
Ort der Integrität was erwarten sie dann
überhaupt von ihrer Teilnahme
jetzt ich bin klimaaktivistin weil ich
überzeugt bin dass es sich lohnt zu
kämpfen ähm dass wir uns reinhängen
müssen das ähm sehen wir auch in der
Menschheitsgeschichte ganz
unwahrscheinliche Dinge wurden immer
wieder möglich gemacht weil Menschen
genau dann wenn es sehr sehr hart war
und wenn es sehr unwahrscheinlich war
nicht nachgegeben haben und das ist
meine Motivation und das bringt eben
auch ganz viele andere Aktivisten hier
nach Dubai zu dieser sehr skurilen
Konferenz es ist aktuell der einzige Ort
auf der Welt wo wir das Pariser Abkommen
verhandeln können wo man echte
Fortschritte auf dieser politischen
Ebene erreichen kann und deswegen ja
geben wir alles und ähm machen Druck ich
habe am Anfang der Sendung noch eine
Frage aufgeworfen was bringt so eine
Klimakonferenz überhaupt auf der im
letzten Jahr die Zahl der Öl- und
gaslobbyisten die Teilnehmerzahl der
meisten nationalen Delegationen
überschritten hat was sagen sie
dazu ja das war ähm eine ganz
befremdliche und ähm erschütternde
Erfahrung bei der letzten Klimakonferenz
bei dieser Klimakonferenz gehen wir auch
davon aus dass hier endlos viele
Lobbyisten sind die halt aus so einer Öl
und gasperspektive hier alles dafür
geben dass Klimaschutz nicht kommt dass
Klimagerechtigkeit schon gar nicht kommt
dass weiter Öl und Gas geplündert wird
als gbst kein morgen im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes und auch deshalb ist die
Präsenz von der Zivilgesellschaft und
auch von der informierten Wissenschaft
hier vor Ort so wichtig um ein
Gegengewicht darzustellen um eine andere
Realität aufzuzeigen und um eben im
besten Falle die Öl- und Gasindustrie
davon abzuhalten sicher durchzusetzen
einfach nur für ihre
Profite ich hab es angesprochen wir
wollen auch über Kritik sprechen an der
Friday future Bewegung die
internationale klimaschutzbewegung
fridos for future die stand in den
letzten Wochen massiv in der Kritik für
Aussagen über den Krieg zwischen Israel
und der Hamas deutsche AktivistInnen
auch sie haben sich distanziert doch die
Frage bleibt wir so wie sehr hat das die
der Bewegung dem eigentlichen wichtigen
Thema den eigentlich wichtigen Themen
geschadet und wir schauen jetzt erstmal
einen Rückblick darüber von Beatrice
Steine ihr sucht Hoffnung bei uns
Jugendlichen wie könnt ihr es
wagen wir stehen am Beginn eines
Massensterbens und alles worüber ihr
sprechen könnt sind Geld und die Märchen
vom ewigen
Wachstum wütend blickt Greta Thunberg in
die Augen der Staats und Regierungschefs
in New York vor dem un Klimagipfel
damals wird sie für ihren direkten
provokanten Appell gefeiert vier Jahre
später steht die Ikone der weltweiten
Fridays for future Bewegung massiv in
der Kritik für ihre antiisraelis
aen auf einer klimademo springt ein Mann
auf die Bühne er wolle übers Klima reden
nicht über
Palästina tunberg ruft es gebe keine
Klimagerechtigkeit auf besetztem
Land Fridays for future Deutschland
distanziert sich von ihr beim Einsatz
gegen Antisemitismus mache man keine
Kompromisse sagt Luisa Neubauer das
Gesicht von Fridays for future in
Deutschland sie kennt Thunberg seit
Jahren traf mit ihr sogar die
exkanzlerin gemeinsame Aktionen wird es
wohl vorerst nicht mehr
geben F Jahre lang war Fridays for
future international über Ländergrenzen
hinweg einflussreich Millionen sind im
Kampf für das Klima geeint auf die
Straße gegangen sie haben es geschafft
Parteien Institutionen unter Druck zu
setzen wie sehr schadet jetzt die Kritik
der letzten Wochen jetzt auch Ihnen ganz
konkret ihrem Einfluss vor
Ort wir merken hier bei der
Klimakonferenz dass die
Zivilgesellschaft präsent ist dass sie
da ist dass sie gehört wird und die ist
ja viel größer als die FE Feature
Bewegung alleine und was wir als
Aktivisten merken und auch ich
persönlich wir sind jetzt seit 5 Jahren
bei diesen Klimakonferenzen und das
macht es viel einfacher sich hier
zurechtzufinden die Zugänge sind klarer
die Gesprächskanäle sind klarer das
heißt hier hat sich echt was entwickelt
und davon können wir Prof profitieren
das macht unsere Arbeit im besten Fall
erfolgreicher und strategischer es ist
gerade nicht leicht hier für uns intern
sagen in der in der eigenen Politik
verstrickt zu sein das ist total klar da
sind wir nicht naiv rangegangen
gleichzeitig ist es eben auch für uns
als Bewegung auch als deutsche F of
future Bewegung eine Zeit der Klarheit
wir sehen gerade noch mal ja in anderer
Klarheit mit wem wir hier auf auf einer
Ebene zusammenarbeiten wo wir vielleicht
schwere Gespräche führen müssen oder
könneno wir gerade keine Gespräche
führen können und das heißt wir sehen
gerade auch dass sich unser Aktivismus
weiterentwickelt dass sich unsere
Bewegung die die Form der Bewegung
verändert und unser Aktivismus im besten
Falle ja in den in den nächsten Wochen
und Monaten
wieder ja eine eine neue Grundlage
findet sicherlich in einer etwas anderen
Konstellation aber im besten Falle eben
mit einem gemeinsamen Wertefundament
sind sie jetzt alleine für sich Friday
for future Deutschland oder wer sind
ihre Mitstreiter jetzt auf der
Kop hier auf der Klimakonferenz treffen
wir ja auf ganz ganz viele Bewegung
Akteure Institutionen Organisationen aus
der ganzen Welt und die allermeisten
sind nicht weides V future sondern die
sind die kommen von überall und die
haben andere Bewegungen andere
Geschichten und mit vielen von denen
haben wir über die Jahre ganz ganz
erfolgreiche Partnerschaften und
Zusammenarbeiten aufgebaut letztes Jahr
z.B haben wir mit der Zivilgesellschaft
im Senegal eine gemeinsame Allianz
aufgebaut um zu verhindern dass
Deutschland dort in ein neues Gasfeld
investiert und wir hatten Erfolg wir
haben Druck gemacht und das hat richtig
Wirkung gezeigt auch so gehen wir wieder
diese Kop ran wir sehen Potenziale und
Möglichkeiten überall das ist ja auch
notwendig denn die Klimakrise ist
dramatisch und sie verlangt von uns dass
wir uns zusammen tun wir brauchen da
globale Zusammenarbeit ganz ganz
dringend und gleichzeitig führen wir
eben für uns hier in der Ver
füterbewegung die ganz dringend
notwendigen Gespräche ich glaube
allerdings auch man muss ja ein bisschen
erwartungsmanagement betreiben wir
werden jetzt auf dieser Klimakonferenz
neben währenddessen wir die Klimakrise
probieren irgendwie ein bisschen zu
besämftigen nicht auch noch Frieden
schließen können über alle anderen
möglichen K Konflikte die im Rah stehen
ich glaube das ist eine falsche
Erwartung ein User bei uns schreibt bei
Youtube fragt sich fragt sie nennt sich
Martin haben Sie vor Ort den Eindruck
dass sie auch gehört werden oder wird
man eben als Aktivist Aktivistin
belächelt wir haben wir führen Gespräche
auf allen Ebenen in Regierung wirklich
auf allen und das in der großen
Ernsthaftigkeit wir sehen auch dass es
eine immer informiertere oder dass
dieusagen die Medienpräsenz hier
deutlich informierter wird über die
Jahre das heißt wir sehen hier wird
wirklich Expertise auch eingeladen
in in Medienbeiträgen noch mal
einzuordnen was passiert das ist total
wichtig weil es gibt eine große
Öffentlichkeit in der Welt die sozusagen
sehr sehr wenig verstehen kann bisher
was hier eigentlich abgeht und warum
hier alle Menschen auf der ganzen Welt
im Endeffekt betroffen sind von dem was
hier behandelt wird wir haben nur was
hier verhandelt wird wir haben nur einen
einzigen Planeten ein einziges zu Hause
das heißt wir ist ist eine riesen ver
ung die in diesen Wochen da ist und das
gute ist wie gesagt die
Zivilgesellschaft hier ist vielfältig
die Restriktionen sind immer noch da
aber hier wird gekämpft und das ist das
wird sichtbar und deutlich hier wird
gekämpft sagen sie sie sind vor Ort um
Druck zu machen dass echte Lösungen
zustande kommen eben nicht nur
Greenwashing was sind ihre möglichen
Möglichkeiten ganz konkret um Einfluss
zu nehmen um sich zu
zeigen ja was wir im Vorfeld gemacht
haben das war glaube ich sehr wichtig im
Vorfeld von dieser Kop haben wir schon
mal kleit unseres Skepsis geäußert ne
die die der Präsident dieser Kop ist ein
ein Boss eines Ölkonzerns hier ähm der
hätte eigentlich von seinem Job als CEO
zurücktreten müssen unserer Wahrnehmung
zumindest für den für den Verlauf dieser
Klimakonferenz damit hier nicht mit
doppelseitigen Interessen gehandelt wird
das haben wir problematisiert und wir
haben gemerkt dass Sultan aljabar der
koppräsident sich dort auch angesprochen
geführt er hat sich mehrfach sozusagen
sehr vehement gerechtfertigt wir haben
gemerkt dass diese Kritik tatsächlich
getroffen hat wir haben auch im Vorfeld
eingefordert dass es mehr Transparenz
gibt zu Lobbyisten die hier sind gerade
von Ölkonzern auch da haben wir gemerkt
da hat man dann gesagt oh moment okay
stimmt für diese Transparenz wollen wir
ein bisschen was sorgen auch das hat
schon so ein bisschen was gebracht in
dem Sinne und wir haben natürlich auch
immer wieder das machen wir auch während
der Kop angemahnt dass wir uns in einem
Land treffen wo die Menschenrechtslage
ähm dramatisch ist wo keine
Pressefreiheit herrscht wo
Menschenrechte überall eingeschränkt
werden wo politische Gefangene auch
jetzt immer noch in äh in wahrscheinlich
dramatischen Verhältnissen in
politischer Gefangenschaft sitzen auch
das hören wir von allen Seiten das kommt
an und das können wir als Aktivisten
machen im Gegensatz zu vielen Staaten
und Regierungschefs die hier sind die
anders auf ihre diplomatischen
Beziehungen achten müssen die sich da
vielleicht nicht trauen die richtige
Sprache zu nutzen die es von der Lage
her bräuchte das heißt hier kann der
Aktivismus im besten Fall auch eine
Lücke füllen die sonst offen bleiben
würde und dann hier vor Ort während den
Verhandlungen ähm ist natürlich muss
muss ich das so vorstellen sind die
diese die Realität hier ist ja sehr eng
während hier die ganzen wichtigen Staats
und Regierungschefs rumrennen große
wirtschaftschefs und alle möglichen
anderen Menschen wird ja sehr genau
geguckt was passiert hier vor Ort das
heißt wir sind mit unseren Protesten mit
unseren Aktion mit unseren Gesprächen
ganz anders sichtbar weil hier sind ja
einfach gerade dann alle das heißt wenn
wir uns hier äußern wenn wir uns hier
zusammen tun dann ja wird das ziemlich
gut gesehen tatsächlich ist unsere
Erfahrung zum Schluss noch die Frage an
Sie sehen sie irgendwo aktuell Hoffnung
Ansätze dass wirkliche Veränderung für
mehr Klimagerechtigkeit passieren
könnte ja was ich erlebe in in
Deutschland und auch überall sonst wo es
das Leute gerade reinweise die Hoffnung
aufgeben weil die Klimakrise sich
verschärft wir rasen eben auf 3° hin wir
sehen überall wie eine klimadystopie
schon aussieht wir sehen dass uns Welten
zusammenbrechen von dem man dachte dass
sie irgendwie immer da sein werden
m und dass Menschen gerade Anfang ganz
frenetisch nach Ausreden zu suchen warum
man sich selbst nicht einbringen kann
warum es alles zu viel ist oder vor
allem warum es schon zu spät ist das
doch ohnehin schon alles verloren ist
und was diese Konferenz in meinen Augen
ganz drinkt sein müsste wäre auch ein
Ort der im besten Fall ein kleines
bisschen Hoffnung geben kann dafür sind
wir hier dafür kämpfen wir dass das
Signal rausgeht es geht voran es lohnt
sich sich einzusetzen wir m wir haben
gemeinsam eine Macht als
Zivilgesellschaft wir können die
politischen Realitäten verändern wir
können ein Zukunft selbst schreiben die
noch nicht geschrieben ist und ich sehe
und das macht mir persönlich Mut ich
sehe hier ganz viele Menschen die das
eben auch wollen und die nach Dubai
kommen den ganzen Weg in dieses
paradoxe diesen paradoxen Ort und nicht
aufgeben gerade weil es so hart ist sagt
Aktivistin Luisa Neubauer vielen Dank
dass Sie heute bei uns
waren gerne gerne und um die Erwärmung
Erderwärmung langfristig bei 1,5° zu
stabilisieren müssten die globalen
Emissionen bis 2030 um 42% zurückgehen
dazu müsste eben das schädliche
Treibhausgas CO2 vermieden werden und so
schnell wie möglich von fossilen
Brennstoffen wie Kohle Erdgas und Öl auf
kohlenstofffreie oder erneuerbare
Energien umgestellt werden aber statt
den CO2 Ausstieg zu senken und jetzt
kommt das Paradoxe setzen unter anderem
Gastgeberland Dubai also das Emirat
Dubai auf eine andere Lösung und wir
schauen mal rein in einen Beitrag
darüber einen Bericht von Jochen Spieß
und Sophia Diesler
dekarbonisierung heißt der Ausstoß des
schädlichen Treibhausgases CO2 soll
vermieden werden ein Problem die Stahl
und Zementherstellung sowie die
chemische Industrie hier können
Treibhausgasemissionen nicht vollständig
vermieden werden dafür braucht es andere
Verfahren etwa das Abscheiden von CO2
aus industrieabgasen z.B mit einer
speziellen Waschflüssigkeit dafür werden
die Abgase heruntergekühlt und in einen
Behälter geleitet die Flüssigkeit darin
bindet das Kohlen dioxid anschließend
fließt es in einen zweiten Behälter und
wird erhitzt dadurch löst sich das CO2
wieder und kann abtransportiert werden
auch aus der Umwelt lässt sich CO2
gezielt herausfiltern riesige Anlagen
saugen die Luft an und trennen das CO2
vom Sauerstoff und Stickstoff ab doch
wohin mit den Tonnen von Treibhausgas es
wird verdichtet und zusammen mit Wasser
tief in den Boden in vulkanisches
Gestein geleitet im Idealfall
versteinert es dort innerhalb von 2
Jahren CO2 aus eabgasen wird häufig
zuerst über Zwischenlager und Pipelines
transportiert anschließend presst man es
in tiefe abgeschlossene gesteinschichten
unter Umständen auch in ehemalige
erdgaslager wie die Speicherung von CO2
in Deutschland genau geregelt werden
soll wird noch beraten bisher sind
solche Verfahren recht teuer
energieintensiv und aufwendig dennoch
wird die Gesellschaft in Zukunft auch
auf sie angewiesen
sein wir haben jetzt die Möglichkeit
über eure konkreten Fragen ich schaue
auch parallel in den Stream ihr habt
auch schon ein paar gestellt jetzt einem
Experten zu stellen denn bei uns ist
jetzt Klimaforscher Niklas Höhne er ist
auch live in Dubai Leiter des new
climate Institutes in Köln das CO2
Emission weltweit analysiert hallo schön
guten Tag Herr Höhne schön auch dass Sie
bei uns zu Gast
sind hallo wir haben es eben gerade im
Beitrag gehört da war von CO2
Abscheidung CO2 Speicherung also von
verschiedenen Verfahren die Rede wie man
eben statt den CO2 Ausstieg zu senken
mit dem CO2 umgehen kann sagen wir es
mal so also die haben wir jetzt
kennengelernt diese verschiedenen
Verfahren können solche technischen
Innovationen unser Klima retten ist das
die Idee und wir machen alle weiter so
wie
vorher ja das ist so ein bisschen die
Hoffnung der Öl und Gasindustrie aber
das ist leider ja ein Wunschdenken damit
funktioniert ganz bestimmt nicht das ist
wirklich eine Scheinlösung also man kann
das vielleicht technisch irgendwie
hinbekommen aber es ist extrem teuer die
probeanlagen funktionieren nicht
wirklich und es wird derzeit als Ausrede
benutzt einfach mehr Kohle Öl und Gas zu
produzieren und das geht eben nicht wenn
wir das Klima wirklich ernst nehmen und
die Klimawandel ernst nehmen dann müssen
wir raus aus Kohle Öl und Gas ohne
irgendeine Hintertür und das müsste hier
jetzt eigentlich bei der Klimakonferenz
beschlossen werden gibt's denn konkrete
und schnelle Lösungsvorschläge fragt
sich bei uns Christian Moser im
Stream ja manchmal malt mal alles so
schwarz und sagt es geht irgendwie zu
langsam voran aber es gibt einige
Bereiche die sind tatsächlich schnell
genug für dieses 1,5° Ziel dass man sich
in Paris gesetzt hat
Solarenergie z.B und auch wind solar hat
sich in den letzten Jahren so schnell
entwickelt die Kosten gehen so schnell
runter das überrascht uns jedes Jahr
wieder dass es so schnell geht und das
ist tatsächlich schnell genug für das
1,5° Ziel und andere positive Nachricht
ist dass der Absatz von Elektroautos der
ist auch schneller als gedacht weltweit
auch so schnell wie es fürs 1,5° Ziel
sein sollte das zeigt für mich wir
können das also wenn wir das wirklich
wollen als Gesellschaft dann können wir
eine so schnelle Transformation
hinbekommen wie es nötig ist aber wie
nicht in allen Bereichen ist das so aber
in einigen schon ja wie wie realistisch
ist das aber überhaupt also dass die
Welt bis zur Mitte des Jahrtausends
keine Emissionen mehr ausstöß wie viele
Staaten es sich nach Paris 2015
eigentlich vorgenommen hatten wie soll
das zu schaffen
sein ja mit einem weiter so
[Musik]
funktioniert das ganz bestimmt nicht da
muss ir Ruck durch äh die Länder hier
gehen und wir müssen eigentlich in den
Notfallmodus schalten also wirklich
alles dransetzen um Emissionen zu
reduzieren und aus meiner Sicht ist der
erste Schritt gemacht also in Paris
gab's so die Idee eben auf null
Emissionen zu kommen und jetzt haben
sich fast alle Länder tatsächlich auch
das Ziel gesetzt klimaneutral zu werden
also auch Länder wie China Indien die
sich lange gestreut haben die wollen
jetzt auch klimaneutral werden das Ziel
ist gut aber die Umsetzung da harpert es
noch sehr ähm und da müssen wir jetzt
alle mithelfen äh aber der erste Schritt
ist getan und das ist ja schon mal gut
und das gab es eben vor dem Pariser
Klimaschutzabkommen nicht da gab's die
Idee überhaupt nicht auf Null
Treibhausgasemissionen zu gehen und das
ist ebeno ein Effekt den man sieht von
diesen Klimaverhandlungen sie sind nicht
wertlos sondern sie können tatsächlich
Änderung hervorrufen auch wenn es
langsam vorangeht schauen wir mal
gemeinsam auf eine Grafik die bei uns
hier in der Redaktion auf jeden Fall ein
paar Fragezeichen ausgelöst hat als wir
die gesehen haben die können wir jetzt
mal einblenden da geht's um die
geschätzte Entwicklung der fossilen
Energien bis 2050 die Quelle ist hier
die Internationale Energieagentur was
wir da sehen weil sie herhöhne können
das natürlich nicht sehen sind das alle
drei Brennstoffe in dem Fall Gasöl und
Kohle dass die also steigen und einen
Höhepunkt erreichen bis 2030 aber dann
fällt die Kohle rapide ab aber Gas und
Öl das bleibt hoch woran liegt das so
eine
Prognose dann nicht dass alle fossilen
Treibstoffe nach oben gehen das war
nämlich das Bild dass wir noch gesehen
haben haben vor 5 bis 8 Jahren da
dachten wir noch es geht eigentlich nur
Stall nach oben und das ist jetzt
abgewendet also alle diese Brennstoffe
zum ersten Mal überhaupt sehen ein
Maximum und gehen dann runter das ist
gut
ähm aber es reicht eben vollkommen nicht
aus Kohle ist der CO2 intensivste
Brennstoff da geht es jetzt auch
tatsächlich schnell voran ähm Öl
sieht nicht so gut aus und bei Gas ist
es sogar ein bisschen rückwärts viele
denken das wäre eine Brückentechnologie
äh dass man das sozusagen äh noch äh
übergangsweise nutzt das geht aber
leider nicht mehr dafür haben wir keine
Zeit das haben wir zu viel vertrödelt in
der Vergangenheit wir müssen direkt weg
von kohleöl und Gas hin zu erneuerbaren
und Energie sparen nur dann funktioniert
das und ja bis jetzt halten sich noch
die fossilen Brennstoffe aber darum sind
ja alle Länder hier versammelt das
möglichst schnell zu ändern und die
Userin Sarah Gille bei uns im Stream die
treibt eine Frage hier um die hat sie
gleich zweimal gestellt die ist nämlich
auch wirklich sehr wichtig sie fragt
sich wie viel Zeit bleibt uns denn
überhaupt noch um etwas was zu bewirken
also in was für einer Zeitspanne stellt
sie noch hinterher muss was konkretes
passieren um das noch zu
stoppen also ganz wichtig ist zu sagen
alles hilft immer ja also jede Tonne die
wir einsparen führt zu weniger
Temperaturerhöhung egal wann und wie
viel davor schon passiert ist ja also
aufgeben wäre Blödsinn das wäre keine
gute Idee und je mehr wir einsparen umso
besser um soo schneller und für das 1,5°
Ziel wird es in der Tat eng dafür müssen
wir global Emissionen halbieren bis 2030
und dann Null erreichen bis 2050
ungefähr da müssen wir uns richtig
anstrengen aber wenn wir das nicht
schaffen dann müssen wir trotzdem
weitermachen und vielleicht nur ein
kleines bisschen dieses Ziel
überschreiten um dann irgendwie wieder
zurückzukommen also es lohnt sich immer
etwas zu tun und jede Aktion ist wichtig
mit Abstand auf Platz 1 was jetzt in dem
Falle kein besonders guter Preis ist ist
China als CO2 Emittent liegt also ganz
weit vor und es gibt aber Stimmen von
Fachleuten die glauben dass Chinas CO2
Ausstoß bereits ab dem nächsten Jahr
sinken könnte glauben Sie dass das kommt
und wäre das dann vielleicht auch ein
gamechanger auch das ist eben eine neue
positive Nachricht auch für China hatten
wir geglaubt dass die Emissionen immer
raufgehen dann hat sich eben nach dem
Pariser Klimaschutzabkommen auch China
ein Netto nullziel an
klimaneutralitätsziel gesetzt und im
Prinzip boomen gerade die erneuerbaren
Energien enorm in China aber leider eben
auch der Energiehunger geht hoch
und das bedeutet dass dass sich so ein
bisschen ausgleicht aber die Hoffnung
ist dass irgendwann Energieverbrauch so
ein Maximum erreicht und dann die
Erneuerbaren in den Markt drängen und
die Kohlekraftwerke ja einfach
verdrängen und dass dann auch
tatsächlich die Emissionen runtergehen
das ist die Hoffnung auch bei der
Elektromobilität ist China inzwischen
Marktführer enorm viele elektroautos
werden dort verkauft
das ist auch ein ein gutes Zeichen und
insofern ja china ist ein bisschen
sorgenkinde ein Viertel der globalen
Treibhausgasemissionen aber auch da
bewegt sich etwas wir sind noch nicht
ganz da es müsste eigentlich noch ein
bisschen früher passieren aber na ja
immerhin es geht in die richtige
Richtung ein weiterer User ein Stammuser
von uns würde ich fast sagen Ike heißt
er nennt er sich fragt was kann die EU
bzw Deutschland noch tun um die globale
Transformation rasch
durchzusetzen ja ganz wichtig hier bei
den Klimaverhandlungen sind es immer
vorreit da zuu haben ja also die viele
Entwicklungsländer der globale Süden der
bewegt sich eigentlich nur wenn der
globale Norden
etwas macht also für Deutsch und EU es
ist unendlich wichtig die eigenen
Klimaziele zu erreichen das sieht in
Deutschland gerade nicht so gut aus
und da müsste man eben nachlegen das ist
extrem wichtig und der zweite Bereich
ist wir haben man kommt einem immer so
vor als ob wir so klein werden in
Deutschland aber wir haben sehr viel
Einfluss in Deutschland wurden die
erneuerbaren Energien gefördert massiv
mit sehr viel Geld wir zahlen das heute
alle noch mit hohem Strompreis aber das
hat dazu geführt dass die Erneuerbaren
inzwischen so günstig sind dass sie
überall auf der Welt genutzt werden auch
von denen die sie vorher gar nicht
nutzen wollten also wir haben da als
Deutschland doch einen riesen Beitrag
geleistet und genau das ist es was die
EU als Ganzes und wir eben als Teil
davon in Deutschland leisten können eben
gewisse Technologien voranzutreiben weil
wir ja dieenigen sind die äh am meisten
am Klimawandel äh schuld sind und die
wir auch omisch weltweit gesehen immer
noch sehr sehr gut da stehen und
deswegen ist es in unserer Verantwortung
ebeno etwas zu tun sagt Klimaforscher
Niklas Höhne live aus Dubai vielen Dank
dass Sie bei uns
waren ich danke ihnen wir haben gerade
über Deutschland gesprochen die Rolle
Deutschlands Kanzler Scholz ist heute
auch in Dubai eingetroffen zu den
Beratungen der Staats- und
Regierungschefs zum Beginn der Beratung
denn morgen geht's auch da weiter
während dieser Konferenz und außerdem
auch heute das war war auch ein Thema
von Scholz was er heute besonders groß
natürlich gemacht hat fand der auftagt
des sogenannten klimaclubs statt den er
unterstützt wir schauen mal rein in
einen Bericht von Mark
Hugo statschuss in Dubai für den
klimaclub der Bundeskanzler hat ih
mitgegründet der Club ein Bündnis aus
inzwischen 36 Industrie und
Entwicklungsländern gemeinsam wollen sie
die Wende vor allem für die
Schwerindustrie die sich noch schwer tut
klimafreundlich zu werden deshalb müssen
wir insbes
für die Perspektiven der Industrie und
der wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung
sicherstellen dass wir gleiche Maßstäbe
haben ein Beispiel wie internationaler
Klimaschutz immer konkreter werden kann
sagen Beobachter bei dieser Kop kommt es
eben drauf an auch dass wir wirklich
Maßnahmen sehen auch in verschiedenen
Sektoren und das ist jetzt eben eine
Initiative von einzelnen Ländern für den
Industriesektor da etwas voranzubringen
am Ende muss man das daran messen was
wirklich passiert aber es ist ein guter
Start hier auch den Industriesektor in
den Blick zu nehmen noch aber steigt der
weltweite
Treibhausgasausstoß ebenso wie die
Temperaturen um inzwischen schon 1,1° im
Vergleich zur Mitte des 19 Jahrhunderts
mehr als 100 Regierungschefs und
Staatsoberhäupter kamen in Dubai schon
am Vormittag zusammen nicht weniger als
die entscheidende klimaschutzwende
wollen Sie hier schaffen am Ende der
kopmus fordert der UNO Generalsekretär
vor allem eines stehen das Aus für
kohleöl und
Gas die Wissenschaft ist eindeutig das
1,5° Limit halten wir nur wenn wir
endgültig aufhören fossile Kraftstoffe
zu verbrennen nicht reduzieren nicht
mindern aussteigen mit einem klaren
Zeitplan morgen wird der Bundeskanzler
vor dem konferenzplenum reden dann wird
verhandelt Ergebnisse soll es in rund
zwei Wochen
geben bei uns ist jetzt unser
Umweltexperte Andreas Stamm der
beobachtet das Treffen der Staats- und
Regierungschef und der Entscheider und
entscheiderin hallo
Andreas ja hallo guten Abend Scholz sagt
über den klimaclub wir verstärken
lediglich die Zusammenarbeit zwischen
den Ländern die bereits sind noch einen
Schritt weiterzugehen erst am Donnerstag
hat das Oberverwaltungsgericht
Berlin-Brandenburg geurteilt die
Bundesregierung muss mehr tun um die
Klimaziele zu erreichen wie passt das
zusammen ja das ist eben der Spagat den
der Bundeskanzler hier hint en muss und
der wird auch sehr genau beobachtet denn
Deutschland gilt auf dem Pakett der
internationalen Klimadiplomatie durchaus
als Vorreiter als ein Land an dem man
sich orientiert das als großzügiger
Geldgeber gilt und wenn ja so ein Land
in Schwierigkeiten kommt dann ist das
natürlich auch hier eine Meldung und ja
Olaf Scholz versucht eben das Beste aus
dieser heikelen Situation zu machen die
Klimapolitik die Finanzierung seiner
Klimapolitik die der Bundesregierung die
ist ihm um die Ohren geflogen da muss
nachgearbeitet werden nachge bessert
werden da geht es eben um das große
Ganze um Milliarden um den Haushalt 2024
und ja da was soll er tun er jetzt was
er hier versprochen hat die Hilfen die
hier ja sozusagen auch von Deutschland
gezahlt wurden 100 Millionen in den
neugegründeten Fond für Schäden und
Verluste das sind alles Haushaltstitel
die jetzt mit der aktuellen Krise nichts
zu tun haben die sind eingestellt für
2023 das geht so durch aber langfristig
mittelfristig im nächsten Jahr und no in
den kommenden Jahren ist das nlich ein
massives Problem Niklas Höhne hat ja
auch eben schon erklärt Deutschland ja
hat mit solchen Finanzierung mit solchen
Anschubfinanzierung viel getan und
darauf hofft man natürlich auch
weiterhin auch in der Transformation in
der deutschen Wirtschaft auch die
deutschen Wirtschaftsbosse die hier sind
sagen wir brauchen das wir wollen das
und ja das wird eine mammutaugabe und es
gibt ja nicht wenige die sagen dass die
Koalition das in Berlin gar nicht
aushält das ist weit weg von Dubai aber
spielt eben hier auch eine Rolle du
begleitest für uns diese Kop eben auch
schon die Vorbereitung dazu hast
natürlich auch jetzt schon im Vorfeld
berichtet über die Kritik an dem präsid
ent wir hatten es im auch schon als
Thema in dieser Sendung Luisa Neubauer
hat auch angesprochen er ist
gleichzeitig Chef des staatlichen
Ölkonzerns des Emirats ist von ihm zu
erwarten dass so ein Mann tatsächlich
Interesse an Klimaschutz
hat ja und nein ich meine auch die
Manager und Macher hier in den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten wissen
natürlich dass irgendwann das fossile
Zeitalter zu Ende gehen wird und dass es
eine Zeit danach gibt und dann will man
hier den Reichtum der ja noch gar nicht
so lange hier existiert vor 50 60 70
Jahren sah Dubai ganz ganz anders aus
und auch die Menschen teilweise
Analphabetenquote extrem hoch also das
hat sich hier in einer Art und Weise
geändert und da will man natürlich nicht
hin zurück man will weiter gute
Geschäfte machen mit grünen blauen
Wasserstoff auch mit Solarenergie den
Technologien der Zukunft aber das wird
dauern und so lange wird man hier alles
dran setzen davon kann man ausgehen Öl
und Gas weiter zu verkaufen und das ist
der Spagat auf der anderen Seite weiß
man eben auch man kommt bei solchen
Konferenzen aber auch beim Klimaschutz
international allgemein eben nur voran
wenn man die gesamte Welt mitnimmt und
das sind eben auch die
töl förördernden Länder und dieser Mann
hat eben auch Einfluss nach
Saudi-Arabien nach Qatar Oman Russland
Venezuela wo auch immerhin er ist ein
gewiefter Manager und vielleicht kann er
Dinge erreichen die andere nicht
erreichen können also das ist ein sehr
zwiespeltiges Ding und im Endeffekt
werden es die nächsten zwei Wochen
zeigen aber z.B dass es im Vorfeld diese
geliegten Dokumente gab wo es dann hieß
dass ja der Präsident und sein Team die
Gespräche die
regierungskult oh mann das ist ein
schweres Wort um die Uhrzeit die
regierungskonsultation ja weltweit dafür
genutzt hat die Ölinteressen von adnok
irgendwie ja zu bewerben das macht's
natürlich schwierig zu glauben dass er
hier ein neutraler Broker ist haben die
Sendung begonnen mit der Frage werden
denn die Stimmen von den AktivistInnen
wie Luisa Neubauer gehört überhaupt du
bist ja live vor Ort bekommst also mit
was sie für Protestaktionen machen und
was natürlich sonst so rund um die
Konferenz passiert was würdest du sagen
was ist dein Eindruck werden diese
Stimmen
gehört auf dem Konferenzzentrum ja denn
hier ist es erlaubt zu demonstrieren
Protestaktionen durchzuführen aber das
ist eben nur sehr begrenzt die Stadt
außenrum alles was außerhalb des Expo
Gelände liegt hier wo diese Kop
stattfindet ist tabu es gibt die
Versammlungsfreiheit in der Verfassung
der Emirate aber das wird wirklich nicht
gelebt das ist nicht vergleichbar mit
dem was ja die Aktivisten Aktivistin in
Europa oder Nordamerika tun könnten oder
wollen aber sie werden hier gehört viele
haben natürlich aufgrund der ja
schwierigen Menschenrechtslage auch
beschlossen gar nicht erst zu kommen
aber andere Gruppen haben eben gesagt
wir müssen dabei sein es ist 5 VR 1 VR
vielleicht schon nach 12 aber wenn dann
nicht wenn dann hier wo dann sonst also
das war ein Zwiespalt sie werden gehört
aber es ist glaube ich nicht in der Form
in der es anderswo möglich wäre
Einschätzung von unserem Umweltexperten
Andreas Stamm danke dir für deine Zeit
ihr habt's ein paar Stunden später so
spät am Abend
danke und danke natürlich auch für eure
Zeit für eure Fragen für eure Kommentare
die Kop geht weiter und ihr seid darüber
auch jederzeit bei uns informiert bei
ZDF heute wir werden darüber berichten
für heute für heute Abend vielen Dank
und
tschüss